hey everybody it's me rain wilson and
i'm reza aslan and okay here's something
that you don't know about me rain a lot
of people don't know this about me
please don't overshare
i bleed
silver and black i am a vulcan
that's green oh that's green you nerd
i'm taking away your nerd card right now
boom
i am a
die-hard
lifelong
oakland raiders fan
that is astonishing it's sad it's
astonishing i mean
i don't know if you would look at me and
you would think that dude is a raider
fan well i would it's not even looks i
wouldn't make that by looks i would make
it like you're a phd in like comparative
religions and philosophy
dude i don't know how thinker and you're
a huge raiders fan i don't know how to
explain what happens to me
on a sunday
when the raider game is on i mean i'm
self-aware enough to know that something
shifts in my psyche yeah
it's it's almost it's like dopamine
almost like i see the team
on the screen
my heart
rate jumps a little bit my skin kind of
tingles i like to watch while i'm
standing i don't like to sit i don't
like to watch with a group i actually
don't like to watch football because it
interferes somewhere other people yeah
yeah because it's like you know it's
it's like watching uh
the seventh season of game of thrones
with your father-in-law who's like uh
who's that guy
what is that is that a dragon
what's with the dragon whether the
dragon lady uh i want to just watch it
by myself in my bubble for for three
hours
and
you know i'm not proud of this but it
does it it really affects me i'm going
to say three words to you and i want to
see how these three words land
las vegas
raiders oh my god it's like knives
in my skin
those who don't know they're probably
moving to las vegas they are moving to
las vegas but you know here's the thing
i'm still gonna i'm gonna [ __ ] about it
but i'm still gonna follow them you're
still gonna watch the stupid you know
i'm gonna call you vegas from now on as
soon as they move i'm gonna be like hey
vegas what's up oh it's gonna kill me
[Music]
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way presented by cast media and soul
pancake
[Music]
well i have a confession to make to you
you probably knew this a little bit more
because i'm a little more active about
it on social media but i am a huge
tried and true die-hard seattle seahawks
fan there's a lot of other sports teams
i like and i have loved through the
years including the seattle supersonics
which breaks my heart to even say those
words but um i went to my first football
game when i was 11 or 12
in 1978
to the kingdome and watched you know jim
zorn and steve largent uh play for the
for the seahawks and watched a bunch of
games then ignored sports for 10 or 20
years and have slowly like come back
around but i i got to see the seahawks
crush
and kill in the super bowl that was
amazing they beat the broncos and
um i got to be there with my son i got
to he got to experience that
incredible rush so i feel yeah well i'll
tell you there's two things surprising
about what you just said number one that
you are a seahawks fan and number two
that you think i follow you on social
media
uh
when you're at that stage doesn't
everyone you're at that stadium okay
yeah it's like 80 000
people going bananas yep right yep
everyone's wearing the same clothes
everyone is chanting the same chance
everyone is focused mind body soul on
the same thing and it can be a very
diverse crowd yeah black and white and
brown and every color and people who
would normally loathe each other in the
real world but in this stadium yep it
feels kind of like a religious
experience doesn't it it does in a way
it is kind of a religious experience now
there's a lot to being a sports fan
apparently americans spend 58 billion
dollars a year on sporting events
billion
i completely believe that so there are
some different aspects to being a fan it
can actually have negative effects
uh after a loss fans are more likely to
be unproductive and eat unhealthy food
oh i can tell you much worse than that
but i will say this
i'm a worse dad
on sunday nights than i am normally i'm
a worse husband like how oh yeah i could
track that why my wife tells me this
my wife literally says to me like first
of all why do you torture yourself why
do you
you know they're going to lose why do
you put yourself through it and that
sounds like somebody who doesn't know
anything about sports or frankly
religion yeah um
uh because like my experience of
religion is all about torturing the self
um
but i'm i'm on cloud nine if we win and
i am just
depressed if we lose i'm literally using
the word we as though i had anything to
do with either the win or the loss and
those raiders fans they're kind of
they're crazy beasts they're known as
kind of the worst it's a very ugly ugly
group to be a part of but hey you know
here's my theory in a world in which we
are feeling
uh less spiritually inclined you know in
which we have less contact with religion
in which sort of we're looking for
different ways of belonging
you know sports is the most obvious way
of belonging right i mean it has all
similar rituals as you that you find in
a religion
similar emotions that you get you know
from from religion you can even
occasionally have these transcendent
moments right moments of like profound
miracle
those are things that i think people
yearn for and sports
gives that to you which i which by the
way is why what we call sports now
thousands of years ago used to be called
ritual
right you know whether you're talking
about native american uh games in which
uh you know the the losing team would
literally be sacrificed although i read
recently that they now they think that
it wasn't the losing team it was the
winning team the winning team got their
heads cut off and sacrificed to the gods
i read that too and i got a way to go
out something
something feels what a way about this
yeah so it's fascinating idea sports as
religion there's so many
parallels can we get salvation from
sports yeah but can we get community
from sports we certainly get that i mean
when i went to the seahawks winning the
super bowl i had maybe more emotions in
that two to three hour span than i've
had
in most of my life that would be a top
10 emotional experience so a lot of
people would agree with that i i get
that so our guest uh gotham chopra
is
sounds familiar yeah i think we both
kind of know him a little bit he
co-founded the religion of sports a
collective media company with tom brady
and michael strahan and he works a lot
with kobe bryant but he believes not
only that sports
is religion but that sports is better
than religion so maybe sports will be
our salvation reza maybe that's what we
need to save our souls our pathetic
little souls is more sports let's hear
from gotham
[Music]
for people listening that don't know
this you are the son of the
world-renowned
mystic self-help spiritual writer of all
time deepak chopra what i just thought
it was a coincidence yeah same last name
no yeah no one ever brings that up but
how interesting oh come on you have to
bring it up people don't know this so
our listeners need to understand like
where you're coming from so you were you
were shuckled at the teat of deepak
chopra's delicious brown breasts did he
did he really make you suckle his teeth
no
because i was going to say this
newsmaking right now
but so you grew up with a
spiritual zeitgeist in mind and yet you
were a young uh
you know avid sports fan growing up in
the boston area so before we get to the
big question
give us a little background the origin
story so to speak
so i'm first generation american you
know i'm the first person in my family
to be born outside of india and i grew
up in boston
you know my father contrary to you know
i think people obviously associate you
know him now with this movement you know
over the last 20 30 years the new age
movement the self-help movement but my
father was a immigrant he was a he came
to this doctor a doctor he came to this
country in the early 70s during the
vietnam war
he
worked as a physician first in new
jersey then in boston and was very sort
of working class and typical sort of of
that generation
we had that sort of immigrant experience
growing up so i was born in 1975 in
boston you didn't have a guru experience
you had a working class doctor
to support a family my dad's transition
into i guess the world that people
associate him with now
guru hood was when i was a teenager
right so it was probably like when i was
13 14 years old that started to happen
for him his
his own
spiritual now persona was precipitated
by his personal experience he was you
know a miserable physician
who called himself a certified drug
pusher you know he wasn't there to heal
people he was there to pass out you know
prescriptions
all through that experience sort of my
cultural assimilation as an american was
through sports teams i grew up in boston
80s the celtics were actually the only
really good team the red sox were cursed
when you talk about another sort of
patriots were a joke pages were a
complete joke um you know bruins always
lost to the canadians in any sort of
major um sport sporting of our hockey to
me like everything that my star my dad
started to talk about in spiritual
traditions when i was a teenager i
experienced through sports i would go to
fenway park you know as i don't want to
be critical of my my teams but so let's
just call fenway park a sacred site you
know it is a cathedral you know there's
a lot of mythology there the whole
cursed franchise you know something i
grew up with it was a real thing it
wasn't like some sort of metaphor it was
true like you went there and you
witnessed in 1986 i witnessed you know
the curse in action so all of these
things you know were very real to me as
my dad started to talk about them i
would sort of point to
sports and say well no it's it's
happening here of course now like
there's all this science that's catching
up with like sports and monitoring you
know um the zone and flow state and
stuff like that so my dad's sort of
increasingly in my realm but you know
look this was also the evolution this is
only like the last five or ten years um
you know before that i definitely did go
through my rebellious stage you know
coming out of college and and doing
other stuff but i think you know my
perspective growing up you know with my
father is like everything is spiritual
so yeah that's kind of like
was like the formative years for
religion of sports and everything i do
now i feel like was sort of conceived
during that time i'm curious what like
how your dad would respond when you
would come home and be like
i'm telling you dad you know uh baseball
it's like it's like what you're talking
about it's like uh it's faith it's
spiritual he would just sort of roll his
eyes you know i think it's interesting
because now
science and technology has caught up a
lot like so he's obsessed with things
like the zone or flow state and all of
that and understanding it so all of a
sudden he's got like sports trains for
those listeners for those couple dozen
listeners that don't know what flow or
zone state is what what what is that and
how does that so a lot of factors you
know i think like the most common one
you hear is from runners runners talk
about the runner's high which is this
idea of like getting to a certain state
you know during athletic performance
when
actually your pulse goes down you know
blood flow increases you lose the
experience of time and you are just
present in the moment so you talk to a
lot of runners i think that's the one
that a lot of you know just normal
people have experienced where like the
fatigue sort of goes away and like they
just feel like very but flow state can
happen with artists and musicians yeah
exactly the creative development
revelation
the muse well it sounds like what you're
describing to me sounds a little bit
like um you know what happens when
you're in flight or flight
moments you know where like your
jurassic brain starts to take over and
it's like i can lift a car um but it's
happening
almost in a in a controlled way yes so
last year we did a story actually a
podcast on a um
an amateur wrestler jeff cannonball
guerrero jeff is like one of those guys
who is an accountant by day but then on
weekends
wrestles in these sort of amateur events
and stuff like that and he's like
one of those crazy i don't know if you
do what jeff does it's like that sort of
performance art crazy wrestling like
heel like hammer like a screw into his
head just like do really bizarre stuff
but when you talk to him about why he
doesn't jeff will tell you it's like i'm
my true self i'm my most authentic
version of myself when i am in that
forum tom brady will tell you the same
thing or kobe bryant like when i'm out
there you know doing that thing in front
of 80 000 people half of whom hate me
seattle fans raiders fans like i am
the best version of myself i don't have
to sort of check any part of myself and
we're talking about from the athlete
perspective there's something about that
level of authenticity and that is a
spiritual quality when we are the best
version of ourselves when we are the
truest version of ourselves operating at
our full capacity and kind of fulfilling
our purpose
on this planet and not worried about
like you know the the haters no worries
actually and this is something that a
lot of athletes deal with it's like you
can get get caught up
you know with all the people who are
cheering against you or hating you you
can equally get caught up with all the
people who just have like this blind
devotion to you that's dangerous like
you know it's it's sort of walking the
middle path the sort of staying detached
from the criticism
um okay so you're saying sports isn't
like religion it is religion convince us
yeah look sports in my opinion is
religion because in organized religion
you need to have faith you have to
believe you have to you know subscribe
to sort of dogma in sports and again i'm
gonna actually speak from the fans
perspective is one that i'm much more
familiar with is you have to show up
like if you go to a game you become part
of a community it may only last for a
couple hours but like you go to that ex
that event and you become part of a
community of people like church
exactly i mean it transcends race
religion sexuality lifestyle
socioeconomic class for those three four
hours when you're sitting at a seahawks
game or raiders game or whatever like
you're not thinking about your political
divisions i'm mostly worried about my
life and my safety actually raiders yes
keep going raiders is sort of called
yeah that's more like a cult it's more
like a death cult
but i hear what you're saying yes
being a pet parent is a huge
responsibility we all know this and
since our pets can't talk we have to do
our best to understand what's going on
but it's challenging because knowing
something's up with them and their
health and
really getting to the bottom of what's
happening it's one of the greatest
challenges
of any pet parent
enter
fuzzy
let me ask you a question right yeah you
ever spend hours googling how to take
care of your pets i don't know about
hours but i've spent a long time sure
yeah and you've got i mean you've got
pigs and stuff that's even more
complicated i just have hamsters i used
to have a bird and a dog and
i mean i'm constantly having to google
stuff like why is my dog sneezing all
the time and what happens when your dog
constantly eats his poop what's great
about fuzzy is you can skip
crowdsourcing recommendations from you
know all the forums and social media
that you go through with a trial and
error and you can get answers
immediately
fuzzy is a telehealth service for pet
parents that offers 24 7 access to
personalized pet care from veterinary
professionals from everyday questions to
middle of the night emergencies fuzzy
has the answers pet parents need through
live chat and virtual vet consultations
available to you 24 hours a day seven
days a week fuzzy can answer your pet
questions big and small urgent and
everyday fuzzy can also recommend the
exact right products for your pet all of
which are hand-picked by their
established team of veterinary
professionals and available at discounts
hello discounts exclusive to fuzzy
members from getting your pets diet just
right to meeting their middle of the
night needs to finally figuring out what
makes their breath smell that way i.e
poop eating nothing is too big or too
small for a quick fuzzy call right now
fuzzy is offering our metaphysical
milkshake listeners a free 7-day trial
membership all you got to do is go to
yourfuzzy.com
meta
to sign up that's a free 7-day trial at
y-o-u-r-f-u-z-y
[Music]
com
yourfuzzy.com and for a limited time
fuzzy is also offering a special
discount of 20 bucks off any of your
pets product needs that's pet meds
supplements food whatever all you got to
do is use the promo code meta m-e-t-a
that's yourfuzzy.com
for your free trial of fuzzy with access
to 24 7 personalized pet care and vet
recommended products
folks kick off 2022 with a better
checking account with no monthly fees
chime
chime is an award-winning app and debit
card that has no overdraft fees foreign
transaction fees monthly fees or service
fees with over sixty thousand fee free
in network atms at many locations like
walgreens 711 cvs you can access your
money when you need it where you need it
you can also send money to anyone even
if they aren't on chime
fee free for you and no cash out fees
for them make your first good decision
of the year and join over 10 million
people using chime sign up takes only
two minutes and doesn't affect your
credit score you can get started at
chime dot com slash milkshake that's
chime dot com
slash milkshake and usually rain the
actor does this part but i'm gonna show
off myself here we go
you're not to let me do the fast no
here we go
banking services provided by a debit
card issued by the bank court bank of
oh
oh you suck
that was you do it banking services
provided by a debit card issued by the
bank corporate bank or stride bank n a
members fdic get fee free transactions
that any money pass atm in a 711
location at any all point or visa plus
alliance atm otherwise out of network
atm withdrawal fees may apply sometimes
pay anyone instant transfers can be
delayed the recipient must use a valid
debit card or be a chime member to claim
funds
we witness right we we talk about
miracles and they're part of our
mythology and and scripture and
religious traditions we witness them in
sports like right like things that
should not happen cannot happen have no
statistical likelihood of happening
happen right in front of us
and and so we're witnessing miracles
we're witnessing the miracle we're
watching jesus walk on the water or
transform
i know we're going to get into this our
athletes gods and stuff and i that's
something that makes me a little
uncomfortable talking about them i think
these are priests yeah so yes if we
shaman really that's probably right for
him to actually pull that about part but
traditionally we think of gods as like
these perfect beings right and i think
that is a very dangerous place to go in
particular with a lot of athletes you
know and i've worked with a lot of them
i mean they may do
incredible mythical things
on the basketball court or you know on
the football pitch soccer pitch etc you
know outside of that they're very human
what oftentimes these athletes do
and what we get to witness and actually
participate in is pretty incredible so
maybe not gods but demigods
yeah yeah i mean to me this like sort of
cements the
the idea that sports is religion i mean
the level of idolatry in in sports you
know and then of course fallen gods you
know antichrists anti-heroes all of
these sort of metaphors truly exist in
sports but there are other aspects of
religion that i don't see the metaphor
carrying
just curiosity afterlife
god is there
moral morality yeah what about like sin
well look i actually to me like this
even proves the theory more right of
course there's sin of course there's
corruption of course there's scandal
deflategate
you don't deflate the footballs
that breaks the rules you don't work
with the trainer and then oh i lost my
cell phone you don't
fumble the fallacy and have the raiders
recover it and then just simply say you
know what never mind let's invent
something called the tuck rule god damn
it tom brady i mean this is like the
growth of religion has been about
rewriting the rules right um is there
sin absolutely right like there's
cheating i mean there is cheating in
sports right we see it all the time and
that is a form of corruption
salvation redemption yeah you're right
all of those things
[Music]
you've said that
it's not just that sports is a religion
it's better than actual religion it's
active like right like every weekend
every night actually it's revealing
itself like we witness these amazing
stories these inspiring stories they ask
us to sort of question our beliefs like
organized religion
in my opinion requires a level of blind
faith you just have to believe like you
can't really don't you just have to
believe that the seahawks are the
greatest team or the raiders are the
greatest team where the patriots are the
greatest team there is a leap of faith
that you make there yeah but then you go
to those games i mean i've been a
patriots fan for 20 years so it has sort
of reaffirmed my faith but it also you
question things things happen it's an
act of faith it's an active process but
that's how faith works for a christian
or a muslim too i think that
faith is changeable in that way like
terrible things i know so many people
have faith where terrible things happen
in their life their daughter had got
brain cancer i know this guy and he
really really challenged his faith to
his core like can there be god can there
be jesus can there be salvation and
redemption when this has happened to me
it feels personal um and so there's
there's years of wrestling with
uh whether these things are true or not
yeah and i don't want to be critical
especially when you bring up an
experience if somebody's faith got them
through a situation like that
then it deserves tremendous admiration
and praise right if if something like
that gets you through
if your faith gets you through such a
difficult
life
questioning challenge i think though and
i especially you know think in terms of
the times we live in and just how
divisive everything is sports is
actually a really interesting
incubator
where you can find like living breathing
evolving principles i think we live in a
time where increasingly we're
questioning all of these things around
organized religion and and science and
cosmology is
is forcing us to question some of these
things that we've held on to for
millennia and meanwhile like in the
sports realm like we can participate in
things we can see a lot of these
inspiring stories again just far away
from because you know there's a business
to sports that we can't not unlike the
catholic church for example um but i
think there's something at the community
level that is really inspiring that you
can touch and you can feel you know
where i felt that the most recently was
the us women's national soccer team
where it's the metoo kind of age and
there's been this wonderful uprising of
women's voices and women's rights and
you know questioning these
horrible ways that women have been
subjugated in the workplace and whatnot
over the over the centuries and that at
the same time here's this woman's soccer
team they're exciting charismatic
figures and all of these girls millions
of young girls across america have been
growing up playing soccer you know from
when they were six eight ten everyone i
know who has girls that could play
soccer religiously using air quotes
they're playing soccer religiously and
here are these heroes stepping on the
stage and there was a national kind of
galvanizing
of passion and
exuberance uh
that was really
wonderfully unifying yeah inspiring this
i mean
this is part of that whole notion of
sport it goes back to the olympics right
the the idea that the the olympics were
events that you did as an act of worship
as an act of sacrifice to the gods you
know specifically to apollo etc but that
notion of um sport and identity in the
way that it that it matches um how we
identify ourselves the way that it
blends into our national identity i mean
i think it's really
in america we sort of
rank our sports
uh in terms of you know importance and
value kind of in the same way that we
rank uh our religions like to me uh
christianity is baseball right it's like
quintessentially american and it's
mostly for white people um
like judaism is like soccer like we all
get it more or less some of us are fans
some not so much you know like the world
cup is like hanukkah you know even if
we're not crazy about it like we'll
we'll still watch
how far
to me like islam is like tennis like
it's an acquired taste you know
uh and then hinduism for me is like
cricket because
no one knows what the [ __ ] is going on
what is what is this what is happening
but we do that right we we rank sports
here is this a global phenomenon or is
this mostly in america no actually i
mean i think america has sort of
popularized this thing and it's sort of
like you know pushed the boundaries but
i think like when you look at foot
soccer or football um you look at
cricket you look at some of these sports
that are hugely popular around the world
and have so much sort of depth to them
and and have so much sort of history and
richness and expressed themselves in so
many different ways i mean soccer is the
ultimate expression of the religion of
sports in terms of its many many many
many endless denominations you know
across the planet and that you know from
the biggest pitches like so you know fc
barcelona versus real madrid it's
probably the biggest rivalry in the
world and part of its rivalry is because
of the politics of of faith you know it
is
two sort of quintessential fates
battling themselves out but then you
look at like the most rural places on
the planet where there's soccer pitches
i mean there are these places in
buddhist monasteries in tibet where you
know the soccer pitch is the sort of
hallowed ground do we then even need
religion anymore if we have sports like
we i mean we are as a as a is the answer
more sports then yeah yeah i mean what i
think look i think there's aspects and
there's wisdom contained in sports that
we can we can mine and that can help us
live more meaningful and fulfilling
lives so statistically you're starting
to see fewer and fewer people of you
know the millennial generation and
younger who subscribe to traditional
faith who consider themselves religious
and yet
there's an increased hunger for
spirituality a search for meaning and
purpose and alternative ways
understanding so look i think the i
think sports is a forum and it's not the
only one i think you know you see it in
arts you see it in music you see people
finding aspects and sort of mining that
wisdom so i do think sports is that
place i think we will continue to see
the
slow i don't call disintegration of
organized faith but it just doesn't have
the answers that i think a lot of people
are searching for let's not forget that
many people would say well wife beatings
go up in local communities when that
football team has lost that day there
are dark sides to this there are fans
that are pummeled to death in the dodger
stadium parking lot like you know my
wife can't hardly watch football because
it's just so violent and she really
ascribes that it is bringing out kind of
some of the worst most war-like natures
of us
for our entertainment i mean that's the
little bit of
and i think that's look i would also say
because i like the you know one of the
things there's this article that
recently came out but about mohamed
salah the
football player for he's egyptian he's
muslim uh he plays for liverpool and
there was an actual statistic that saw
over the last year where he i think you
know was probably the most popular
player in the premier league the
hate crimes you know anti-muslim crimes
went down in liverpool working-class
england wow during may the past year
because this guy
you know sort of broke all of those sort
of conventions
today's episode is brought to you by
huel my favorite nutritionally complete
food
every huel meal contains the 27
essential vitamins and minerals protein
healthy fats and fiber i need in a
single meal and right now
let me tell you rain i am loving their
macaroni and cheese now mac and cheese
is one of my all-time favorite meals
everyone's all-time favorite meal and
huel's mac and cheese tops that list it
has all the nutrients my body needs 27
essential vitamins and minerals and is
only 400 calories per serving and it has
25 grams of plant-based protein i'm
getting more protein than four eggs all
the vitamin c of an orange more calcium
than a yogurt more potassium than a
banana and one bowl of fuel mac and
cheese wow it only takes five minutes to
make for lunch you just add hot water
you can make it in the free on-the-go
pot they give you with your first order
you can take it wherever raza it's like
they've made this super healthy fast
food everyone needs fuel mac and cheese
in their life especially if you're super
busy and a mac and cheese lover like me
it is so delicious and creamy oh you
won't be able to tell that it's
plant-based and you know what huel has a
whole range of other meals that are
perfectly balanced with all the
nutrients your body needs they've got a
bunch of flavors like mexican chili
thai green curry again all of them
nutritionally complete and made in five
minutes or
less plus i love how easy it is to work
heel into my routine keeping me happier
and healthier no matter how busy i am
you gotta try it we're partnering with
huel to give all my listeners a free
t-shirt a free on the go pot and free
shipping with your first order go to
huel.com milkshake to take advantage of
this offer
supporting my sponsors helps me make
this show for you dear listeners so show
huel some love
claim your free t-shirt free on-the-go
pot free shipping with your first order
at huel.com slash milkshake huel
h-u-e-l-dot-com
slash milkshake folks let's get real
okay i think we can all probably up our
fruit and veggie game
it's hard keep track getting eating all
the veggies so much kale i've eaten so
much kale this year i want to change
that i want to up my game that's why i'm
keeping my freezer stocked with daily
harvest daily harvest is the easiest way
to get more fruits and veggies in my
life every day they have my back with
delicious food that is good for me and
good for the planet daily harvest
delivers delicious harvest bowls
flatbreads smoothies and more all built
on organic fruits and vegetables right
to your door and it conveniently stays
very very fresh right in your freezer
we're so obsessed with it my wife eats
like daily harvest every day she's
ordered so much daily harvest there's no
more room in our freezer for literally
anything else
it's full of like okay we got the
broccoli and cheese harvest bowl we love
that one the the tomato and zucchini
minestrone soup
they got this like banana ice cream
thing they got like these okay okay well
you get the idea listen daily harvest
takes literally minutes to prepare and
never uses preservatives added sugar or
artificial anything and that goes for
everything so many delicious options for
every time of the day breakfast lunch
dinner snack or dessert as reza is going
on about daily harvest has you
covered daily harvest is all about
preserving and protecting the earth for
current and future generations to come
daily harvest also makes it easy to feel
good about what you're doing for
yourself
so
go to dailyharvest.com
milkshake and you can get up to 40 off
your first box that's dailyharvest.com
milkshake for up to dollars off your
first box daily harvest dot com slash
milkshake your household too
can have fights over who gets the daily
harvest dessert
[Music]
so how does sports fandom differ from
other kind of fandoms that also have
like uh spiritual or religious
significance um
is k-pop
you know is that a religion star wars
you know the comic book geek marvel
culture i mean each of them has totems
they've got practices
and literally the fans of k-pop stars
call them idols oh my son's dyed his
hair he is now on because of his
fascination with k-pop oh yeah in order
to be a religion there has to be a a
depth and a mythology and a history to
it and that's why i think sports
qualifies i think music does i think
k-pop i've not steeped well enough to
know necessarily is capable of
phenomenal your son is going to rebel
against you just like you did against
your dad and he's going to be he's going
to write about the the spirituality of
k-pop
these kids i don't understand this you
know i would say even within the realm
of sports like you're seeing like
esports like this fascinating
phenomena but this is how all religions
start right as like this sort of cult
like with this following when people are
like no way that doesn't make any sense
i don't get that like that's certainly
that makes no sense this is a fad
and then lo and behold this is how
you know ufc started if we were having
this conversation five ten years ago i'd
be like man that's some crazy [ __ ] like
nobody that's just for freaks you know
yeah and now you know it's a
multi-billion dollar industry it's
carried on espn yeah it's a you know
it's a real sport and it's a corporation
you know and so like i think these
things evolve over time and they evolve
rapidly now so
can sports save us and if so how i think
there are aspects of sports that can
save us i'm looking at tom brady or
steph curry and i'm saying what can i
learn from you
and your
performing at the highest level and
having that sort of spiritual experience
and apply to my own life tom will tell
you like he talks a lot about like his
mental energy and how he
channels all his mental energy towards
the two things that are most important
to him his family and his football and
everything else is a distraction and i'm
like hey why don't i do that like i need
to do more of that in my life and i
think those are sort of principles that
we can learn and then you go back to the
fan experience i think like why is it
that i can go to a game and for three or
four hours like i can just commune with
everyone else in that stadium like i can
we can resonate on a on a limbic level
i'm going to get hippy dippy and i'm
going to say that there's this book i've
been reading team human by douglas
rushkoff that's what we need to learn
from sports we're all one team guys
we're all really one team we're humans
on a planet and there's eight billion of
us almost and can we root for each other
and cheer each other on and strive for
our best and and work together i know it
sounds hippy dippy airy fairy no but
there's something to that so
lightning round lightning round describe
your soul in 10 words or less
not a yankees fan
what's one thing you know for sure my 12
year old son who's soon to be you know
bigger than me i mean that is the one
true relationship i have in mind like my
wife may not love that answer but it's
it's pure
and then finally what is your life's big
question why are we here
what is our purpose does god exist
that's three but three big questions
kind of wrapped into one gotham chopra
thanks so much for joining us today this
was really mind expansive i'm definitely
never looking at sports the same again
and i'm never looking at tom brady
period
you're amongst the converted now
[Music]
well that was super fascinating i love
gotham great guy great guy
you you started out this episode a
little bit skeptical about his whole
point of uh
sports being a religion and not just
being a religion but being better than
religion i started a little skeptical
and you know what i'm way more skeptical
right now
i'm skeptical i don't think the um
i don't think it answers so many of the
questions of what religion
uh
answers i don't think it
it goes there i mean there's there's
morality there's death there's the
purpose of life
you know if sports is the religion
what's the purpose to compete to simply
gather and watch competition i mean
there's an aspect of sports that brings
out the worst in humanity think about
bread and circus in the roman times
about you know gladiator fights and in
the in the boat races and chariot races
and stuff like that like there's
something bloodthirsty about it um it's
a
the massive humanity there's there's not
that much difference between a a rally
at nuremberg and a football game you
know what i mean like there's the the
analogy falls apart i think when you
really look at it sorry i don't know i
mean you're kind of
describing religion there with the the
violence and the hatred and the does it
have a purpose
look i hear you i mean i think look the
can sports save us right uh
and i guess the answer is yes if
what you mean is if you've lost any hope
in religion
then it makes sense right like the idea
that sports is religion
only works is if you loathe religion
right if you're basically saying
we want to remove religion from society
and replace it with something else
sports is a pretty good one i guess
because it gives you some of the same
stuff but yeah i mean is it about
existential questions moral choices i
don't know i don't know i feel
but at the same time
i'm now being forced to kind of look at
myself and the way
that i
react to sports especially to the to the
raiders you know like i mean i
i feel like i certainly spend
as much time performing
exegesis on like articles written about
you know raiders training camp
and what like what like the tight end
depth is going to be
depth chart is i do the same thing with
the ceo
i do that more than i read any scripture
that's for sure i do like looking for
meaning in everything that we do and i
love the idea of this great time when
you have a sporting event and it's a
diverse crowd it's black white and brown
and rich and poor and everyone together
with a
commonality of purpose celebrating with
one another
there's a transcendent energy that rises
above the stadium there's some truly
beautiful things to be celebrated about
sport look i like this i like ending an
episode with both of us kind of not sure
maybe this is where we need the
listeners all right okay you guys
you listeners out there
uh it's time for you to to save us okay
so you tell us
we don't know
have you ever had a truly transcendent
moment
uh in sports i mean
i don't mean like excitement because
your team won i mean something that made
you feel like you were out of your body
that you were part of a larger
movement and identity connected to the
cosmos itself
hey milkshakers as usual when you rate
and review us on apple podcasts you get
to come on our show and ask us your
life's big question
and today
we've got john from california
who left us a lovely
review and we're bringing him on hello
john welcome to metaphysical milkshake
thank you so john what's your uh what's
your question for us no i'm just i'm
just thinking about sports and how it
has such a long history in all cultures
and given its super bowl week here in la
i was wondering why you think people are
are so into it and get so dedicated to a
single team
the topic of this week's episode
aligning with the uh the guest that
never happens uh that's true uh gotham
chopra um
is a interview that we recorded uh
recently and
he's all about sports is the new
religion that it has all the aspects it
has everything people are looking for in
a religion it has
you know
transcendent quality it has
the ability to bring people together of
different backgrounds it has um
community
shared interest
um
excitement well i mean it also has i
think most importantly that the sort of
notion of collective identity right
community you know it's
and i think that that to me is is
where it really
uh has that kind of existential quality
as we were just talking about you know i
mean we've already talked about how
wayne and i are big sports are you a
sports fan yeah yeah i'm or uh i just
thought brain probably similar to you
maybe i'm uh i'm from seattle and i went
to the uw so i'm a long time seahawk fan
so i'm i'm a real
reborn rams fan now though so
wait wait wait wait wait wait no no no
no that's that's not how it works it's
john
that's not how it works you grew up in
seattle you're a seahawks fan you don't
move to la and like oh i went to seattle
from l.a so the rams fan first so it's
fair
[Laughter]
okay okay you are forgiven
you are forgiven just like the priest
forgives his flock you see
you see how that works but you know as
we were as we were just discussing um
you know with with gotham it's
there's there's something about sports
that gives us that that sense of tribal
belonging that we just don't have as
much anymore right like
as a nation the concept of like a a
national identity i mean we're so
divided we're so polarized you know it's
hard to say
with any kind of seriousness that like
oh yes we're all americans and we all
bond in that american sense uh you know
racially ethnically like those kinds of
you know old markers of identity just
don't don't do it for us anymore and so
in many ways like sports has become
the primary way
in which we find a sense of community
and belonging in a common language and a
common way of kind of identifying
ourselves and we all sing the same songs
and chant the same
you know chants and wear the same colors
and and perform the same rituals and
as we discussed you know i think that
there is
uh humans are we're tribal creatures uh
fundamentally and
there's kind of healthy tribalism
and there's unhealthy tribalism as
witnessed in contemporary partisan
politics
um
but
uh
sometimes sports can be the very best of
human tribes like we're
diverse and we're cheering on the
underdogs and we're rooting for the
human stories and we're coming together
in support of
you know people
on a on a mission
and there's some it can be really
elating and really beautiful but it can
also result in guys getting beaten to
death in parking lots and we go to our
worst tribal uh instincts yeah what do
you think i think it's very true you
know especially football they've
equivalated it to war in the past too
and kind of win together lose together
but
putting different cultures or different
sports you know you got to fight
canada or soccer in europe or whatever
right so it's crazy so hockey is perfect
because they can just stop the game and
just get into a fist fight can you
imagine if that was the case in every
sport like in curling
they just stopped and just started
pummeling each other and the refs kind
of like
kept everyone else back and let them
like
hammer it out and then said okay
continue you can continue rolling those
little ice balls around funny
i'm i'm going to be honest with you i'm
torn i'm torn here because
uh
the bengals beat the chiefs and as a
lifelong raiders fan as listeners know
i will be forever grateful to the
bengals forever
uh then again the bengals also beat the
raiders
so
little tough
rams i i couldn't give a [ __ ] about the
nfc i've never cared about the nfc
seahawks [ __ ] you guys
but
but la you gotta you gotta root for the
home team the super bowl is at home so i
don't know i'm torn it's a new stadium
it's great for the city yeah i know i i
hope it's a great game too but it's
going to be an exciting week here
another interesting thing about sports
is i heard this fantastic interview with
noam chomsky and he realized that he
thought that americans had a much
greater capacity for a deep political
understanding and passion when he was
listening to sports talk radio because
there would be all these callers in on
am radio stations talking about earned
run averages and percentages and trades
from 10 years ago in the gallery caps
and like the average sports fans
knowledge of sports like my knowledge of
nfl players is pretty staggering i could
probably name hundreds of players in
this league and and chomsky was like
well if if if contemporary americans can
know that much about sports then they
can learn
to be that passionate and that detailed
uh about their uh political ideas
maybe maybe if like chuck schumer and
mitch mcconnell
like uh you know
tackle like fought each other like
yeah sumo yeah yeah yeah
who you rooting for rain for me i guess
i i don't know who i'm rooting for i
guess i got a root for the rams i have a
lot of friends that are rams fans but at
the same time wow that would the bengals
taking the super bowl that would be
that would be historic yeah that would
be fun
that would be a lot of fun
right i'm just a fan of the game
and uh and just wondering where russell
wilson is going to end up next yeah
we'll see
maybe the raiders
maybe we'll see thanks for coming on
john oh thanks for having me guys have a
wonderful day folks if you've got a
question for us it's very easy all you
got to do is rate and review us
ask your question on apple podcasts and
uh who knows we might have you on and
you can ask us yourselves
so hit us up on twitter or instagram i
guess so at reza aslan
wilson
metaphysical
and even though i hate twitter we love
our listeners so write us please and
tell us what you think
and uh you can send us pictures of you
and your most kind of bananas sports
moment if you like
maybe you'll find a picture of renowned
scholar reza aslan ignoring his family
and screaming at the tv at the oakland
raiders on a sunday we'll catch you next
week
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it is produced by safa
samazadeh yazd harris lane mick dimaria
hashem self and dj lubell
cast media is the production and
distribution partner original music by
jeff tang
this has been metaphysical milkshake
presented by luminary media and soul
pancake metaphysical milkshake is
executive produced by rayne wilson reza
aslan gulris lucina and daryush puzuela
no thaft of soul pancake hashem himself
is the head of production
metaphysical milkshake is produced by
amy s choi and rebecca lehrer of the
mashup americans associate producers are
jocelyn gonzalez lindsey crowell sarah
pellegrini mary phillips sandy and
shelby sandlin
[Music]
so you know me and gotham and rayne the
three of us a long time ago got to spend
an entire afternoon at bad robot talking
to j.j abrams about the spirituality of
star wars which means that whatever else
dear listener you do in your life you
will never
ever be as cool as
us that is really not where i thought
you were gonna go
[Music]
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel
thank you